foreign
Health and Human Services oversight
committee for September 22.
uh 2023
and would the clerk please call the rule
we have pending a special appointment of
Dr Palma to be an alternate and then you
will come up to be a regular member for
today only because we have a few things
we have to vote on and you make the
Quorum anybody who leads will be
punished okay
would the clerk please call the roll
foreign
Pearson here representative McDonald
representative Weber
representative Edwards representative
King here
representative Merchant
representative Murphy
represented or I'm sorry I always do
this Senator Rosenwald
Senator gray
and senator avard
thank you we will defer things needing a
vote until
um we I can hear back from the speaker's
office who've been specially appointed
any other alternates is also brought up
to being voting members today to make a
quorum
DHHS Commissioners updates from my
fellow fellow
we were both on a Milbank Fellowship
together so we are fellow fellows
and introduce yourself not that I've
forgotten but yes good morning Marissa
Han associate commissioner at DHS and
commissioner Weaver sends her regards
she actually is a Milbank fellow this
year and they had their first Gathering
um in Utah presently so she is there but
um listening in and um and censor best
so and actually before I start there was
someone else I wanted to introduce or
perhaps reintroduce and that is Krista
Morris who's going to wave Krista is our
new director of intergovernmental
Affairs she started a few weeks ago
um she is back home in New Hampshire
um having previously worked at the
division for Public Health Services as
their legislative liaison and we're very
lucky to have her back now helping
support and work with you all in liaise
with you all as we advance our our
common goals
um that relate to Health and Human
Services so you'll be seeing more of
Krista but just wanted to to welcome her
which means her business cards aren't
ready for district I don't know they're
usually probably not quite ready
um so um
it's giving me the Vital Information
from my phone sometime before you thank
you yeah great
um so I think that okay ahead often
means that someone else is no longer
with us no that is not the case and in
fact is John here today no John Williams
is continuing um this is just to to
broaden the reach of our um supports
Christa's role will
um be engaging in the work and strategy
particularly as it relates to
um the interplay between state and
federal activities so for example um
helping us prepare presently for the
possibility of a federal shutdown and
what that means for HHS what it means
for the people we serve so it's really
just working hand in glove with um John
Williams as he continues to support all
of us in our common state activities so
for the record John Williams is at Lake
Tahoe he says it's for family wedding I
think he's out visiting the cartwrights
all right it's a bonanza for him great
great no thank you for um for asking
that question and we're grateful for for
John for his critical ongoing Services
as well
um so I believe the topic that you
wanted to hear a bit about today is an
update on the Youth Development Center
YDC and its closure and rebuild which we
did talk about one or two meetings ago
um so so I'll be brief and then um
answer any questions you have
but just as a reminder it was during the
last legislative session through hb49
and sb1 that the department was given
the
um requirement to shut the current YDC
which is this new new Services Center in
Manchester and rebuild a facility for up
to 18 Youth
and to determine a location for that and
to include a variety of other
requirements listed in HB 49 we were
also given funding to carry out these
activities and so over the last several
months we've brought on an Architecture
Firm to support the pre-designed design
process
we've engaged extensively with the
community in ways I'll talk about
um and we have completed site selection
so
um as part of that and I should note the
site as as stated I'm sure at the
previous meeting the site where the new
facility will be located is on the same
campus as Hampstead Hospital and
residential treatment facility which is
now under State ownership as of about 16
months ago
um and so we have begun work on that
campus with the Architects planning for
this future home-like architecturally
secure facility to be moved there so
where we find ourselves in the process
is what we call basically pre-design
moving into schematic design I've
learned a lot of architecture and
engineering
terminology in the last month or so but
um fortunately we're really working with
the best of the best when it comes to
HDR the architecture who are engaging in
this project they have 30 years of
experience building juvenile facilities
across the country state of the art
architecturally secure but also very
appropriate to the therapeutic needs of
this complex population them so they
have been working to determine all of
the square footage needs what needs to
go where to ensure that um that this is
a highly secure facility to ensure that
this is a facility with the programming
residential clinical
um components that it needs to to be
highly successful the next phase is
called schematic design which is where
they get all the fancy Blueprints and
design documents prepared all of that is
in preparation for the eventual
transition into a construction phase for
which we'll be doing a competitive
procurement for a construction firm that
bidding will take place next year and
then beginning pretty much exactly a
year from now is when construction it
would actually begin and we expect that
to be about an 18-month period and that
would prepare us to begin the transition
of Youth into the new facility in the at
the end of 2025. so it's a it's a
um appropriate but also I'd say
aggressive timeline
um we need it to be in order to spend
the federal arpa dollars that are
dedicated to this effort
um and we're feeling
um grateful the actual I think what has
transpired since our last meeting is
that the um Architects HDR have been
much more Hands-On in terms of being on
that Hampstead site
um neighbors to uh right probably
basically abetting a representative
Pearson's own property and beginning to
scope out all of the needs how do we
design and and build a building that
meets and needs but also is highly
respectful of um of the land that it
sits on of the water of the desires
concerns needs of neighbors and
community members and that is the last
thing I want to comment on which is the
extensive Community consultation that
has been going on
Senator Birdsell has been convening a
very active and energized YDC impact
commission I think we're on our fifth
meeting and that is a group made up of
different individuals including
ourselves with involvement in this
project as well as law enforcement State
Police Hampstead police fire and the
goal of that commission is to really
understand what are the various impacts
of this new facility on the surrounding
community and how do we mitigate any
negative impacts whether that's traffic
whether that's concerns about safety or
or any issues around that the
architectural design the aesthetic look
of it from the street Etc and so that's
been a very active group and in addition
to that YDC impact commission which is
obviously open to the public and it
includes a subcommittee on safety we've
also had begun a series of community
forums in the town of Hampstead
um and that's an opportunity for the
town to weigh in on what their concerns
are what their feedback is those have
been Lively as you can imagine but but
also very helpful for hearing what the
concerns are what the myths are what the
areas that we need to hear not
surprisingly there are folks who have
concerns they have concerns about what
this means um what you know is it
possible for youth to run away from the
the future YDC facility uh the answer to
that question by the way is an absolute
no when it comes to YDC this is a
state-of-the-art facility and just as no
youth has ever eloped from sysc in
Manchester that will be the case with
the future build which is even more
secure
many of the concerns from our
perspective and representative Pearson
you were at our last meeting so you may
have your own Reflections
um many of them are coming at an
interesting time where Hampstead
Hospital is going through some Growing
Pains to accommodate a more acute
population so again we had this YDC
facility entering the campus we have
Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility on that campus now
under State ownership serving a very
acute population and there are some
challenges that we've faced in terms of
even though we have all of the
appropriate Staffing ratios even though
we have strong contract oversight we've
had to make some important adjustments
to ensure that that facility has the
stability that it needs it has required
some significant partnership with local
law enforcement Fire EMS when things
have happened
um we're proud that thanks to many of
the changes that have been made in terms
of the physical facility locking in
terms of fences that are going up Etc we
really haven't had the issues of Youth
from the hospital running away that we
had for a period of about six or so
weeks those were all fortunately without
incident in terms of any consequences we
were able to round the kids up and bring
them back where they needed to be but we
have now basically prevented that from
happening again at the hospital and as I
said before it will absolutely not
happen at YDC because of the nature of
that facility being so much more secure
we've also engaged in a number of
different leadership changes and
programmatic inventory of all of our
safety strategies to ensure that
Hampstead Hospital is um is not just
preventing kids from running away but
fundamentally managing very acute
escalated behaviors within the facility
appropriately and so
um so obviously we have more work to do
but we're feeling very optimistic about
stabilizing what needs to be stabilized
on the on the hospital campus and I
think that in turn will reassure the
community
of just how important it is for us to be
good neighbors on this growing campus as
YDC makes its move there so I will um
there was one more thing I wanted to
mention and it's escaping me at the
moment uh oh I had one more thing which
is we've also had the YDC steering
committee so this is basically a group
of people who are working side by side
with us as Department of Health and
Human Services or child advocate Etc to
design this physical facility and
representative Pearson has kindly agreed
to serve on that as has the planning
town planning board pres um chair
um from the town so essentially what
we're trying to do is bring in as much
Town voice and town input into the the
both detailed and higher level planning
for that facility so that we can ensure
that it's collaborative all throughout
so I'll pause there
my response would be while the meeting
was unfolding I was more than impressed
with how Senator Birdsall and Associate
commissioner
and
kept the lid on I mean I had 9-1 on my
phone about ready to push the fund on
several times during the meeting I don't
know how you did it but um you kept the
lid on also I am not an architect but my
son-in-law is and so we discussed how it
could be secure without looking like and
so that the people involved would feel
this is a a comforting welcoming and
helping facility and the residents who
all live further away from it than I do
um would know it's secure and I think
the architectural team we have is doing
a very good job
any further questions or comments yes
um representative Murphy thank you you
mentioned they were interesting I'm just
kind of wondering if you could elaborate
on what their major concerns were in the
um in the Forum sure
yeah so the um the community Forum
concerns I'd say I think we drilled them
down to three areas we'll see if I can
remember I mean the first thing that I
and this is not just at this community
Forum meeting it was at the prior one we
had one at the Hampstead Public Library
that was maybe a little less Lively and
then the one that representative
Pearson's describing was held at St
Christopher's church
across the street from the current
campus um which uh despite being a uh
house of worship uh proved to bring
about some strong opinions and feelings
as well that it was but it was all as uh
representative Pearson said I think we
we managed um and and helped people feel
heard so the first thing I mean the
first thing we heard is that this is a
community that really cares about
vulnerable people
um because of that there were comments
made both about the importance of the
services delivered by DHHS but also
concerns about
um elderly individuals who live alone at
the retirement community across the
street and kids who are used to having
you know not locking their doors um on
some of the beautiful abutting
properties and so I think we tried to
focus people on how how that same value
of supporting families and keeping our
families safe and supported is embedded
in in what these um what these DHHS
facilities are looking to do so that was
the first element second was around
really land concerns we've heard
um we have some very expert neighbors
who have concerns about water who have
concerns about the uh everything about
the Topography of the landscape and the
snow plows and we have they have sent us
at times even 17 pages of detailed
analysis which has been very helpful
because it allows the division for
Public Works which is our partner at the
department of administrative services to
be able to ensure we're checking all the
boxes when it comes to engineering
Solutions when it comes to the various
assessments and things we have to do and
we take that seriously we don't have to
as a state go through all of the
approvals that a say private or
commercial property would but we are
going to go before the town planning and
and so forth to ensure that they're
having the input that they need so that
we show that we're we're developing
responsibly so I'd say the first were
around kind of land water
aesthetic and privacy concerns third was
around safety which I think I've talked
about just this kind of perception which
I think we were able to mostly assuage
um that kids are going to be running a
mock everywhere and and that it's a
danger which which we we firmly believe
it's not but we also have more work to
do to be able to stabilize things at the
hospital to to prove that and then I
think the last area of concern was
around Staffing how are you going to
attract the staff to to be at this
facility to to work there when you're
already having challenges at the current
Hampstead Hospital which is a great
question and point and we have a number
of different strategies going on both
within our human resources team to
ensure that we're planning for that but
also
um I think part of what is proving
effective even though some people who
work at sysc are interested in kind of
making the move many are actually very
excited there are going to get to work
at a facility that is that is state of
the art that is a beautiful place to
work that is secure and yet any of us
would would the amount of light that's
going to be flowing in the the quality
of the um the physical
um layout and then the corresponding
impact that has on the people we serve
who are positively impacted by that
design is proving to to to be highly
engaging to many of the staff who want
to work in there and who want to move
over with us so I think you mentioned
the good neighbors and great neighbors
um who including great neighbors dogs
more importantly who uh who sometimes
wander on for our property so um so
we're feeling optimistic but those and
we're also trying to to one of the
things we're emphasizing with the
community is how much we're hearing them
and then the specific adaptations and
changes we're making based on that
feedback
and if yes follow up just follow up
um thank you for that is there a name
for this facility or is it are they
going to name it separately from the
Hampstead Hospital or how is that going
to work out yeah that question has come
up a little bit we haven't figured that
out yet um in statute it is referred to
um as the Youth Development Center YDC
um but uh if anyone has ideas or
creative suggestions I believe
representative Pearson actually
suggested we work with local school
children to kind of get their help
around design around naming around some
of the Aesthetics which I think is kind
of a nice idea as well so that we create
a sense of not just Community tolerance
but Community Pride in this building
director Flagship planning on being here
today
so children's oversight overlap today
with HHS oversight
so you can talk to Senator Carson about
that but um I because of his being on
the agenda over there I told him we'd
tag team
okay
yeah I have some stuff okay anybody else
anything else you wish to present nope
thank you
Media power Youth Organization and
Mission overview
foreign
and you can always bring up a third
chair
Miss Tilly if you want
no I'm good you're good you've got good
people working for you yeah okay
hello thank you for having me my name is
Heather ingart I am the executive
director of Media power Youth and uh we
are a Youth Development organization
dedicated to helping youth build healthy
communication skills through media
literacy and we have been working in the
state of New Hampshire for over two
decades we actually started as a
community health clinic by a group of
Physicians and concerned parents who are
really looking at the impact of media on
the health and well-being of children
and we work on a variety of prevention
initiatives here with different types of
organizations such as the partnership
for drug free NH and local YMCAs Boys
and Girls Club and schools
um before I jump into
introduce your neighbor
hi there I'm Jenny O Higgins I'm a
senior policy analyst for Behavioral
Health with DHHS
good
thank you
um before I jump in too much I like to
spend a little time talking about how we
define media because we look at it very
broadly it's a system of communication
and includes TV
um entertainment like video games as
also movies as well as tools that our
youth are using every day in the
classroom like Google Classroom where
students are using it to complete
assignments and talk with their teachers
is actually a form of social media and
we want to help our kids learn how to
navigate these spaces for their academic
learning and their success in school and
out of school
when we talk about the mission of our
organization we do recognize that media
can have negative effects but we
intentionally frame our mission in a
very positive way our mission is to
inspire young people to engage with
media and thoughtful and creative ways
that support their physical and mental
well-being and it's always about
well-being for us but we want to
approach when we introduce ourselves to
people to show that this is going to be
a start of a conversation and that we're
not approaching it from a place of
judgment
we still we have three buckets of
service youth programs which I mentioned
which I'll talk about today family
educational opportunities that include
parent nights at schools and also
curricula that we and other resources
that we provide to local teachers across
the state
um
when we consider our impact our first
goal is to help people understand what
is this connection between media and the
culture of our community our health and
relationships these are protective
factors that enable us to be resilient
in the face of change and we provide
opportunities to build communication and
critical thinking skills as well as to
understand what are those media habits
that contribute to well-being and which
ones are not contributing to well-being
and we provide resources to a lot of
Youth survey organizations just parent
guides and curricula
we are very fortunate to have a number
of research partners and that help us in
this work we have a long-standing
relationship with the digital Wellness
Lab at Boston Children's Hospital with
the University of New Hampshire the
granite United Way We also more recently
have been working with the University of
Wisconsin's Department of Pediatrics on
a program around teen and Adolescent
mental health and that study was
published in the jmir mental health
yeah we think about media literacy the
foundation of all media literacy is
critical thinking skills for youth so
what are the skills that they need to
make healthy decisions in their lives
and so I'm actually slide six that talks
about some of these skills and what we
hope is in an article like this People
magazine
um that are used when they are reading
this kind of material can recognize this
is actually an ad from influencers that
are tapping into something culturally to
show that
um
to try to make the case that using
alcohol would be part of a healthy
lifestyle and what media literacy
teaches youth is to question this
premise and to learn more so they can
make a healthy decision
the role of Youth voice is very
important to our organization and we
have a youth Advisory board that meets
monthly that informs the work that we do
they share their lived experience and we
build programs off of that it actually
started with a group of New Hampshire
students called our youth design team
where they worked with us over the
pandemic to design a curriculum which
I'm going to talk about and it's their
input in developing this resource and it
was such a positive experience for our
students and they developed something
that was pretty significant as you'll
see and we decided to continue that
experience and make our youth Advisory
Board a permanent part of how we work
um in social media it's really the
infrastructure that our youth are using
to create communities and these are very
interactive spaces and they are how
they're building relationships and right
now
um we often see that that's compromising
their mental health in a number of
different ways we talk about social
comparison social rejection fear of
missing out these are all aspects of
social media that our youth are
experiencing it which is compromising
their mental health
um however there's also a lot of aspects
of social media that contribute to
well-being in terms of social connection
and belonging and so we consider our
role at Media power youth is teaching
youth how to balance these things and
how can we ensure that the behaviors and
habits that they're developing around
this part of everyday life is actually
contributing to their well-being
we have a number of different resources
and programs here it's just a sample of
all of the programs in our portfolio we
do have a lot of parent programming that
we do including a service called digital
Wellness for families where families can
actually come together and discuss their
own values and what type of healthy
media habits they want to create at home
and so our programs are really driven by
the participants themselves and we
deliberately structure them that way
foreign
I did include in the presentation a few
pictures of some of our different
programs that our kids are learning
through hands-on experience and the
research shows that when students are
creating media about something that's
important to them it causes them to
really consider what are their own media
habits and to use media in ways that are
more beneficial for their well-being and
the well-being of their community
an example of our work is during the
pandemic we worked with Girls Inc and a
music video project which is really
meant to destigmatize asking for help
when you talk with youth a lot of them
are concerned not only can they
sometimes have trouble identifying who a
trusted adult is but they don't often
many of them don't necessarily believe
that if they ask their help they get it
and so the purpose of this music video
project was to show them that asking for
help would be a sign of strength and not
a weakness so they could encourage their
peers to to seek out help throughout the
pandemic
foreign
programming is also very interactive and
we provide opportunities for parents to
actually practice talking about media
with their kids and so they can develop
the language and the vocabulary to
better understand what quality screen
time looks like and so that they have
the tools to address some of these
influences at home
we do have a wide portfolio that
teachers here in New Hampshire can
utilize to teach these skills they range
from fourth grade up through ninth grade
we're also working on some lessons for
younger grades and they're really based
on a unique set of needs based on that
student's relationship at that life
stage and where they are in terms of
their adolescent development they're
designed to be really flexible so that
teachers can use them in a variety of
settings
to teach our kids these critical
thinking skills that they need
yep
um one research that I want to highlight
is around our curriculum that was
initially called digital EQ and mental
health this is the one that was
developed by New Hampshire students and
it has been renamed by the students and
teachers who
um we piloted this curriculum with as
digital climate change and it was all
around one single driving question which
was what would middle school students
need to learn and know in order to build
a safe and supportive Network
so in this curriculum is a project-based
learning module and the students look at
how to recognize and build empathy
skills in digital spaces and so this is
an important tool in school climate
initiatives and also really Empower
students to think about how they're
using these tools and how it's affecting
their relationships in their lives which
you know is a protective Factor they
learn some foundational skills around
emotional intelligence and how to
recognize miscommunication how to
navigate conflict and then they produce
a book a guidebook for their peers at
their school on how to use social media
positively and this can doesn't
necessarily have to be a public platform
like we're not advocating that they
teach each other how to use Snapchat
this can be how do we use Google
Classroom a tool we use every day in our
school in a positive way
uh Miss India because of the time in the
schedule that we have I'm going to now
call on the committee and Dr Palmer we
Grant you permission to speak not vote
we're chasing down that but if we have
any questions for the presenters
while they're preparing that on page 10
of your beautiful wonderful handout you
really know media which is good
um the bottom slide number 20 18 states
currently have media literacy policies
and I S I do not see New Hampshire as
one of them is this in the works
I think we're having a lot of
conversations to write that right um now
about that with the governor's executive
order on social media and mental health
um while I say that we don't have a
specific
um legislative policy there's a lot of
good work being done um in our schools
around media literacy and teaching
skills both in schools and after school
scoutings as a result of the curriculum
that we've made available we do a lot of
teacher training and so I would say
there's a lot of activity happening
although we don't necessarily have a
formalized policy around me to let us as
you evaluate what is going on in numbers
of schools different Laboratories of
testing this we suspect that there will
be a policy initiative forthcoming would
that be something the department would
come up with or would that be presented
to a some legislators perhaps for a bill
filing
so I I think this is the partnership
where we when the when DHHS came to
speak about social media and mental
health we're now bringing in Media power
to talk more specifically about media
literacy and that piece of the education
because this is so new really that we're
continuing to learn and research and
understand what are the connections
between mental wellness and media
literacy it's this partnership to try to
figure out how we how we do this work
together that we're still in and
understanding the policies that have
been passed throughout these other
states whether or not they have
unintended negative consequences or
where they're truly helpful in learning
from that to frame up what does New
Hampshire need I think already we're
doing a lot to close gaps from symptoms
to treatment for our young people and
make sure that we have mental health
education social emotional learning
access to counselors and social workers
in our schools appropriate screening and
intervention to kind of get on tops to
get and stay on top of all of the mental
health challenges but it's the the
complexities between how is social media
creating healthy positive connection and
where is it creating negative impacts
that we're still learning about New
Hampshire has a reputation for being
either first or last in just about
everything the Deans would last is
obvious the danger with first is we're
the ones who are making the mistakes to
learn from them so we do have 18 states
who are doing that for us and I'm sure
that with what you're doing in the
schools and what you're learning from
these 18 states pretty soon we'll have a
policy that we can be proud of that was
a push question
um representative King
first I'd like to thank you for the
report that you gave us in June which
was
titled something similar and I can't
think of it
our group has actually renamed it
technology and the impacts on use and
you gave us a lot of good data and over
the summer we've we've gone and done
even more research on this and one of
the questions back in June was how do we
what are the solutions because it's
always great to bring up a problem and
if you don't have any solutions so here
you come in September and I I see a lot
of solutions here so thank you for the
report in June and the solutions now now
my question is
um
[Music]
from what I understand from this report
kid kids actually got involved you you
did this how did how did you actually do
that
sure
um so we had um an application process
for youth that we sent out for those
that were
um concerned about media use and wanted
to provide guidance to adults teachers
to build programs that would address
some of the challenges that they were
experiencing and then from that we
formed this Advisory Group they were
asked certain questions about their
current relationship with media and
what's really nice to see is that we
have a pretty wide range of perspectives
so some who don't use social media at
all for various reasons it's impact on
their mental health and some who are
Advocates and creators and so we import
we felt it was important to have that
kind of diversity and we meet monthly in
our schedule
adapts to kind of what's going on with
technology at the time and what their
lived experience is
okay great so it was follow up I'm sorry
that's all right thank you Mr chairman
all right so
um
and I'll have one other follow-up too if
I can would you like to buy a book of
six
as long as it's discounted
um
so do you have one single area like a
boys and girls club or is it some some
place where did you go through the
schools
um we both we work across the state and
so often um schools will tell us if
there has been say a lot of cyber
bullying and they need help navigating
and they want to engage their community
in that so we have worked with a lot of
after school programs
um some schools we're doing some
professional development here in Concord
in um in this fall and then we will
um so we'll basically work with many
different types of organizations and we
always start with what are you seeing
what do you need and then how to match a
program that's going to address that
need
okay thank you and my final one yes yes
I can okay and I may I think you can
certainly you may
uh
the the all-important one is the parents
and how are are you seeing parent
involvement uh and then how how did you
actually reach the parents
this is one of the problems that we're
seeing in our communities is a lot of
parents that need this aren't coming
forward so how do we actually find the
parents I will say this is ongoing
because the parents have a lot on their
plates
um and media can be stressful navigating
this with our youth so we will
um there's a couple of different ways
that have worked for us so when we do do
a presentation we'll often work to
provide either
food or have child care or sometimes we
do family presentations so they bring
the whole family together to talk about
this as part of like an after-school
night or an event we've also started to
do some online
um offerings so that parents can log in
and do a virtual session from home and
we will continue to talk with parents
and and
innovate in in what we can do to try to
provide these in a flexible way for them
we also have a standalone parent guide
or that will distribute at various
um
child friendly events we've started to
do more festivals and fairs here in New
Hampshire to be able to reach parents
um when they're out in the community and
to start that conversation
thank you
and if any further I think
representative Murphy you had your hand
up yes thank you um and thank you for
this work I mean it's it's obvious
that we see it personally and even you
know socially around very serious the
importance of social media and its
impact
um my question is
number one is is it fair to say that the
primary mission is not so much the
um the the use and the creation and the
mechanics of social media like the
Hands-On projects but more of a critical
eye to its use in its implications and
it's an impact on society and kids uh
number one question number two if the in
reference to a Chairman's question on uh
slide uh on page 20. if people in other
states you know have this in in fact I'm
specifically thinking about
Massachusetts where is this type of
policy literacy policy housed for like
teachers to access it and understand it
so let me address the first question on
our mission and yes it is the technical
skills the current media creation skills
are
um par is more the pathway it's the
topic area we know youth are really
excited and interested in talking about
media and so we harness that passion and
interest to talk about this bigger
picture so them being critical thinkers
when it comes to the information that
they're presented with and also to be
healthy communicators
um can they express their needs to
others in a positive way and that
translates both offline and also in
digital spaces and that's the core of
what we do the media creation is just
the Innovation so that we're really
engaging students and we know from how
kids learn that that Hands-On component
really helps them to understand the
material
so it's the hook that gets them into the
programs yes
um in terms of your second question
um this will in some places
um be housed within the Department of
Education so it might be credentialing
and ensuring and continuing education
that there is some media literacy
training as part of that sometimes it's
in providing guidance and standards
um in other states it's working with the
local University system to ensure that
as we're training the next generation of
teachers that media literacy is part of
that foundational training that prepares
them for teaching thank you
so just additionally we can email the
committee the policy report specific to
media literacy so you can see what
policies have been implemented in these
other states in more detail many of
which are educational standards around
media literacy but some are broader like
allowing for mental health days to be
excused absences or increase access to
counselors and treatment and screening
in schools and things like that but
there are some that are very specific to
media literacy so we can make sure that
you all have a copy of the national
report
and I will say that one of the
foundations of our organization is that
yes we do work a lot with schools but
now that we're all walking around with
these cell phones is that this is an
environment that our children are in 24
7 and so looking at um experiential
learning in a variety of contexts I
think would be really important for the
well-being of Youth going forward
thank you for your presentation before I
call the next group up I have good news
bad news and good news the good news is
I get a text five minutes ago from the
speaker's office the bad news is from a
different state he's seeking money for a
re-election campaign I'm not kidding the
good news however is
um representative Palmer you are going
to be
um replacing Vice chairman McDonald so
welcome to the big children's table now
you have a voice and a vote and with
that
um I would like to go back and take a
look at the minutes of the June
do we have a second do we have any
comments
wonderful all in favor
aye opposed thank you second item I need
a quorum for which I now have is we have
the Alzheimer's disease and other
related dementia subcommittee of this
committee is Jessica escaland or
Mackenzie Nicholson here
come on up
and not only you know she's here you
know where she's here come on up
good morning good morning and this is
just if you want to say a few words then
um I am just continuing to track people
down we have almost everybody with
updated appointments uh letters uh
reflected in the speaker uh the clerk's
office and updated on the website so I'm
finalizing that uh and I am meeting with
Senator avard hopefully next week to
talk about next steps in terms of if he
is appointed chair today you'd like to
be meeting with him I'd like to think we
are doing the chair suggests to the
committee we finally tracked it down
that the chairman doesn't make the
appointment the committee does at the
chair's encouragement and that no one
else on the subcommittee may be the
chair only legislate to us so I had a
small group to pick from I asked Senator
avard if you would be willing to serve
he said he would be and so I would like
to ask the committee for acceptance of
Senator avard as the chair of this
special subcommittent moved so moved
second in favor
opposed thank you meet with Senator
avard well thank you very much thank you
now
next
chair recognizes Melissa Hardy and Sandy
farrows to give an update on the DD and
ABD weightless quarter this is your
quarterly reports
good morning good morning I'm Sandy
Pharos I'm the bureau chief at the
Bureau of Developmental services and
Melissa Hardy is not with us today she
is out of office yeah
so I'm here to give an update on the
quarterly wages looks like this oh yes
the pie chart the orange and blue pie
chart thank you
that's that's an overview of some of the
data points that I'll be presenting
today the quarterly wait list report
that I'm reporting for today is the
quarter four report for fiscal year 23.
so this covers April May and June of
2023 and in total for the entire fiscal
year for the developmental disability
waiver we were able to allocate funding
for
1193 people
broken down that means that we had 282
people aging into Services we had 58
people that were new to services and we
had
854 people that already received
services that were getting additional
services that totals 1193.
of those people that were allocated
funding we had 54 people that were able
to receive full or partial and this is
the pie chart that's in front of you you
will see that there were 54 percent that
received bull or partial or and 46 that
were unable to receive services
for the fiscal year
so broken down we had 650
excuse me 644 people that receive
services and 549 Services did not begin
for people
that was broken down into specific
reasons that people were unable to start
and the top reason was that there was no
reason I'm sure you picked up on that
one of the challenges when we were
pulling this data was that we were
transitioning from an old system to a
new system of reporting so there are
many blank spaces and it's very safe to
say that the majority of these people
did not start Services due to an
inability for the agency to find a
provider agency to offer the services or
the inability to hire staff to deliver
the services within the organization
so as you can see um as we go through
the reasons we had 22 percent that no
longer requested services so they
changed their mind and decided they
didn't want services and then staff and
provider Recruitment and selecting an
agency were the next two issues that
people ran into in starting their
services
so that's the developmental disabilities
waiver which is adults with
developmental disabilities the next
waiver is the in-home supports waiver
which is for children with developmental
disabilities living at home with their
parents
so for the entire fiscal year we were
able to allocate funding for 130
individuals broken down we had 68 people
that were new to services and 62 people
that were already receiving services but
getting enhancements
of the 130 people 77 were be able to
receive full or partial and 23 percent
of those Services were delayed
so broken down again we had issues
running into staff and provider
Recruitment and 13 of them just no
longer requested services
so moving on from the In-Home Support
waiver onto the acquired brain disorder
waiver which serves people with
traumatic and brain injury and acquired
brain disorder
we have lower numbers for this waiver
totaling 61 people over the fiscal year
that were allocated funding
15 of the 61 were new to the services
and 46 needed enhanced services
now out of the 61 that receive funding
60 of those individuals were slated to
begin services within the fiscal year
so out of those 60 we had 44 that
received services and 16 that did not
receive services or their services did
not begin again challenges around
provider Recruitment and for this
population we had a number of people
that didn't have Medicaid established so
we would have to go and work with them
around establishing their Medicaid
eligibility
are numbers for our three home and
community-based Care waivers within the
developmental Services System
we are working on trying to address the
issues around identifying provider
agencies and supporting agencies so that
they can recruit staff to provide the
services we do understand that that is
the biggest challenge across our service
delivery system
any questions any questions
how aggressive is your recruitment I
know from my day job uh I have openings
too and I'm just wondering what are you
doing more specifically to try to fill
the your Gap
so we have a very busy year ahead and we
just crossed the finish line for our
corrective action plan to becoming to
become compliant with Federal
requirements which everybody is familiar
with our BDS scriptive action plan going
into the next year we're working hard to
develop rates that are based on provider
cost and it's Our intention to develop a
rate that is going to meet the needs of
our provider agencies and also
incentivize
direct support professionals and their
professional growth around certification
and training
that is to say you might take in some
people who are almost there but give
them as part of the package the training
to get there yes and incentivize
providers to do the training for their
staff so that they can improve
Recruitment and Retention within their
organizations good
and thank you for your continued efforts
to interface with the public I know as
one who attends the Hampstead meetings
about that which is in my backyard
um it's difficult dealing with people
and their needs which are very personal
and very real to them but I I want to
thank you for your continuing efforts to
reach out to those folks and thank you
for your support as well and that
stakeholder engagement is a strong
priority for us going into the next year
thank you thank you and thank you for
your presentation you're welcome
um okay we are now up to the New
Hampshire Health Care Quality and
patient safety Commission
annual report
and while I'm putting out brush fires
would you please introduce yourself
now I think you can hear me okay uh good
morning Sharon Pearson and committee
members and thank you so much for
allowing us to present the 2023 annual
report of the New Hampshire quality and
patient
um safety commission my name is Chris
Herring and I'm the vice president of
quality improvement at the foundation
for healthy communities and I'm the
administrator for the commission and I'm
joined by I'm Rory Dodd's Diamond I am
the director from the center for quality
and safety at Southern New Hampshire
health and I'm the current chair of the
commission
I assume you all have copies of the
report
um okay great thank you
um I had some available so I'm going to
just briefly educate you on the purpose
and structure of the commission and then
Rory will get to the good stuff and give
you the highlights of our work for the
past year
so the commission was first legislated
in 2005 and with the purpose of
providing confidential protections for
our New Hampshire hospitals to gather
and to review Adverse Events experienced
in their facilities
discuss root cause analyzes and develop
best practices to improve patient safety
the commission was so successful that in
2019 it was legislated as a permanent
commission and in addition to our 26
acute care hospitals four specialty
hospitals in New Hampshire hospital
Ambulatory Surgery centers were also
invited to participate we have a
designate the commissioner of DHHS that
participates as well as up to three
public members who are really vital as
they bring the voice of the patient and
perspective of the patient to our work
we meet five times a year and in
addition to reviewing Adverse Events
which are required to be reported
mandatory in our state and are very
clearly defined we also wear the de
facto group to examine workplace
violence events which unfortunately have
increased dramatically
this will change with the passage of
Senate Bill 459 and 2022
workplace violence events will be
reported to the New Hampshire Health
Care workplace safety Commission and on
July 1st of 2023
our commission was renamed to include
the patient in it to prevent confusion
so we are officially New Hampshire
Health Care
quality and patient safety Commission
Now
so there's four guiding principles that
the commission
incorporates into their work
the first is promoting High reliability
very critical to ensure that processes
are standardized and that we have
proactive mechanisms to look at
potential error before they occur
we established just cultures in our
organizations
unfortunately ours will occur and it's
critical that individuals well held
accountable are able to feel safe as
those events are reported investigated
and that we take a systems approach to
investigation we adopt evidence-based
best practices to improve outcomes so we
really are looking at science in
developing our processes and Care
recommendations
and we're ensuring that Health Equity
diversity and inclusion are Forefront we
understand and this is where again
incorporating the voice of the patient
is critical that and covet only
emphasized the fact that there are
significant Health disparities and
unfortunately in health care and we need
to address those as we go forward
I have a question at this juncture as
part-time CEO of a small Medical
Counseling and massage center in
Kingston
is a facility like ours or a larger
medical facility mandatory reporters if
there's an incident
so the I'm not asking for a place yeah I
wonder if there were and right so
there's mandatory adverse event
reporting for
um various entities as a private
practice is if I'm understanding
correctly you would not have mandatory
reporting okay you're talking larger
hospitals and other public facilities
that is correct thank you please
continue you're welcome
um at this point I'm going to turn to
Rory for some highlights
so for 2022-23 uh we had continued a lot
of our virtual meetings that we had
transitioned to during covid however we
had some concerns as the executive
committee met that there was not the
same level of relationship and
interaction that we had had previously
so we have made the decision to move our
commission meetings back to an in person
with a remote option for extenuating
circumstances only
um the attendance at all of our meetings
was very high throughout this year with
about 35 to 40 members present at each
meeting
okay
um at each commission meeting we did do
a review and discussion of the most
recent Adverse Events data which DHHS
has provided for us and that's been very
helpful for the commission uh to have a
more real-time view of what's Happening
across the state we have seen similar to
National trends that New Hampshire had
an increase in the number of Adverse
Events reported as the pandemic slowly
began to unwind and through the
commission's work we identified some
Workforce shortages as a major
contributor to those that rise in
Adverse Events we had kind of The
Perfect Storm of high vacancy rates and
then the unprecedented use of contracted
staff which we refer to often as
Travelers which could be nursing Locum
providers other clinicians that come in
we had some new clinical leaders who may
have been inexperienced as leadership
that often got pulled into Staffing
roles as well and were unable to Mentor
some of the new clinicians that were
coming through many of those new
clinicians that were coming through were
during covid so their education looked
very different than what we had
experienced ourselves coming into the
field with a lot of person-to-person
connection a lot of these new staff were
coming in with more remote or virtual
experiences in patient care
um
so recognizing the challenges of the
healthcare environment our commission
has been focusing on best practices to
proactively identify some of the process
failures identify evidence-based tools
to assist clinicians and hardwiring all
the necessary elements for patient care
there is a bit of a Back to Basics theme
in the past couple of years in
unfortunately seeing some of our trends
that had been declining going back up
so some of the topics that we've
discussed over the past year in terms of
quality and safety we had some
representatives from the veterans
administration of Manchester come and
speak about the healthcare failure mode
and effects analysis framework to again
proactively identify risks in new
processes through risk assessments
identify potential failure points remove
system vulnerabilities before the error
occurs
we also had education on
evidence-based team steps program which
is a nationally recognized program to
improve communication and teamwork among
health care workers to optimize those
outcomes for our patients
and the the speaker that we had was
great in terms of providing us some real
things that we could do right away it
wasn't necessarily conduct a bunch of
meetings and get it off the ground but
there are things that we can do right
now to change the way we communicate and
improve that we had some presentations
on new models and strategies to reduce
patient falls and reduce Hospital
acquired pressure injury which continue
to be the most commonly reported Adverse
Events in this state
we had some storytelling opportunities
which are often very powerful related to
surgical Adverse Events to identify
commonalities and nuances in those
events that we've seen we included a
review of updated guidelines from the
association of operating room nurses or
aorn on the use of technology to ensure
accurate surgical counts and prevent
retained forward objects during surgery
and we did do a deep dive into some
one-off Adverse Events we have the
commonly reported Falls and Hospital
acquired pressure injuries but we did
see some Adverse Events that we don't
typically see so we wanted to talk about
what was going on with those what we
were seeing we have seen a surprising
increase in increasing trend of sexual
assaults that are reported so by sharing
the details of these events and the
analyzes and Improvement opportunities
our members were able to share some
valuable insights and tools to assist
colleagues in preventing some of these
similar events from happening in their
own organizations and again movie into
that proactive prevention
um for patient and family engagement we
had a member presentation uh from a
hospital that obtains real-time feedback
from their patients through a volunteer
rounding program where volunteers will
actually go and talk to the patients
while they're in the hospital and
solicit feedback from them oftentimes
we're relying on surveys that occur
weeks or months after the patient has
left the facility where their memories
may be a little bit
um
not skewed or
um just affected by the time but getting
that real-time feedback these um the
volunteers were able to take some
real-time improvements in the Care and
Share some feedback with the staff
they did something they gave some
examples of their service recovery and
the care improvements and that was very
powerful
we were educated on a new model called
experience based co-design to engage two
groups in information gathering and
partnering for problem identification
and problem solving
from this we learned some new ways that
we could engage our patients and staff
to work together improving care for
patients with for example substance use
disorder it might not be something where
you want to pull a team in together but
to be able to interview them separately
get their experiences and bring those
together
they that this process has also been
used to improve the check-in process and
physician practices increase patient
Mobility during hospitalization so a
great new way to get us thinking and
involving the patient in our process
improvements uh we've been very
fortunate to have Dr Ben Shan as a
regular guest at our uh actually a
member of our commission so he gives us
he's looking for things to do until the
next week
but we've been keeping him busy uh so he
provides us every meeting and update on
public health which thankfully we are
still continuing to talk about covid-19
but we're moving into other things that
are affecting the health of the state
including an emerging infection Trends
and the members have that opportunity to
speak with him directly ask questions
about what's coming down the pike we can
share our challenges and provide
suggestions on how Public Health can
better support our work so that's been a
really valuable aspect of our meetings
so we've acknowledged that supporting
that Healthcare Workforce as I mentioned
earlier has been critical in rebuilding
our quality and safety programs in our
organizations we've made it a priority
to share strategies on how to do that
and that is ongoing
um we've talked about developing roles
for non-traditional members to
incorporate to the healthcare team how
can we leverage artificial intelligence
technology to Aid our clinicians The
crucial role of visitors and volunteers
some of those people that we
unfortunately lost during the pandemic
when we shut our doors to both visitors
and volunteers we're now bringing them
back and really embracing what they can
do to assist us in our efforts and
creating that culture of continuous
Improvement through ongoing data
collection transparency and
accountability
so as we enter our 19th year we had our
first meeting in August we remain
grateful to the legislature for this
unique organization a lot of us at least
I do myself refer to it as my my own
peer support network having people
across the state who are in similar
positions to myself to share some of our
challenges some of our celebrations and
really take advantage of that Network
um we're going to be needing to move to
questions in just a minute or two so I
believe that was the end you're all good
um
when someone in one of the public
facilities
um uh the the facility being a mandatory
reporter do things have to Channel
Through the individual of that facility
whose job is among other things to
report or can anybody report I'm looking
at whistleblower if they perceive
reporting was not done that should have
been
how has that happened or maybe it's
never come up
I don't know if you had experience with
that I well there's there's a formal
process for the hospital to report an
adverse event but and I know there's
some folks in the room that actually
patients can call and do call directly
to Department of Health and Human
Services if there is a health care
concern they report concerns sometimes
to the New Hampshire Hospital
Association who then takes that
information back to the originating
organization
um so an individual organization may
have reported it but not everybody
involved me know that so there may be
somebody saying I don't know what's
going on but I'd like them to and they
discover oh it's already underway that's
that could be that's a possibility for
sure because you now have the word
patient in your title so is it it sounds
like it's possible that a patient may
directly report
so I you know I've certainly had that
situation where DHHS has called me and
said we have received a concern from a
patient or from a patient's family
member quite often we do have uh 15
business days in order to report that
and oftentimes we're within that 15-day
window and yes I'm already aware of it
I'm submitting it to you so we have
those conversations with DHHS but
certainly if they shared something with
us that we were not aware of we would
then go and investigate that the patient
would not know of your specific
organization or how to contact it but
they would probably assume DHHS sounds
like a good place to go
yes well we have that on our all of our
websites all of our patients can report
their concerns sounds like it's working
any other questions representative
Murphy thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you for your report
um
the essential events on on page nine
that chart really was flatlined for
about a decade and then obviously it
spiked in covert
does your real-time data currently show
it has gone down in the past year or so
or are we still at a fairly high level
um so
no it has not gone down so where we have
two quarters worth of data uh for 2023
that we're currently analyzing in the
quality commission and our pressure
injuries continue to rise which is very
concerning and we're going to take a
deep dive on that on our October 6th
meeting
um and are other ones uh are are holding
stable but the pressure injuries is an
area that we're concerned about thank
you in the follow-up follow-up
and
so you alluded to this so I'm trying to
think about the root causes and I'm sure
you're looking at it was it specifically
you think a the number of the actual
physical number of care providers that
were present to take care of the surge
or it was at the skill set that was the
problem in taking care of the Surge and
if so are some of the thoughts going
forward a change in the um the models of
care that you know you mentioned
visitors and Volunteers in working up to
your you know your license you know your
skill level and stuff like that so we're
we're as a focus is it hiring more
people or is it basically are we going
to be looking at a different care model
going forward you think
would say yes both okay
um you know the first key is actually
getting people to fill our vacancies and
that's I think a priority but then once
those people are on board we need to
look at how we're providing that care is
there a way that we can do it more
effectively more efficiently and give
them the tools to care for our patients
you know at DH the biggest problem right
now is housing you just can't find
anybody is that the major problem that
you see as far as hiring people or is it
pay levels or how can legislation in any
way help you to improve the the
vacancies that you have
so housing definitely is an issue
um and I know many hospitals have gotten
very creative in trying to uh find and
make housing available for staff
um the stress of the of the workplace is
very high it's very high stress
environment there's high levels of
burnout unfortunately with our
clinicians and our providers
so anything that we can do we're very
excited about the new workplace safety
commission as we feel that's really
going to bring a lot of attention and
focus to that issue and solution
um so anything that we can do to support
that because we need to make these
workplaces a safe place and a place
where people want to be and
unfortunately it's that's been a very
difficult environment and I would say
that we are seeing some stabilization in
terms of we've at least in my own
organization where I work we've had a
lot of people who work contract staff
travel staff who are now flipping too
permanent they're choosing to stay so I
think the appeal of travel has worn off
a little bit and we're also approaching
how we're bringing on new staff and
providing them a high quality
orientation to what we do and how we do
it in terms of your burnout one of the
things I've instituted in the
organization I'm part-time CEO of is
PTSD debriefing I watch my staff I see
not only the circumstances that may make
it possible for this to happen but also
indicators in the individual
suggesting this to another branch of our
government as something they would
Implement
one cause of burnout is the the need for
review with people who have been the
professional in a series of adverse
circumstances are you doing anything
like that now and will you if not will
you start it on Monday
what I I can tell you and I'm really
proud of this is for the past six months
we've convened our New Hampshire
hospitals in a clinical peer support
learning collaborative
and we for the sole purpose of talking
about not just in an adverse event it is
critical in an adverse event that we
support our clinicians and we're talking
providers plus certainly nurses and
others who need this support but it just
in times of high stress so what can we
do to develop those programs within our
institutions what training do people
need to be clinical peer supporters so
there's been a real uptick in momentum
on that and we're at the point of
increasing training now so that
hospitals can develop those programs
formally and informally I'm familiar
with how the fire surface does this and
has done this for years and very well
but could you shoot me a memo some point
on how you're developing it because it
will it will help in the particular
group that I am hoping to initiate this
with absolutely any further questions
that representative Palmer
thank you uh my question is coming from
the having been on peer review for years
and the work that obviously you've been
doing is like where we've all wanted to
to head
um both from the point of view of of not
just blaming people for things but but
also enabling patients and the and the
custodian to be able to bring things to
forward
one of the things we've been talking
about recently is the fact that the rate
of change of various things in working
in a in an institution
really gets ahead and so there's there's
always a new thing that you're having to
learn and what I find now is maybe it's
because I'm getting old is that I'll be
thinking I should be learning something
more about the actual job I do but now
I'm going to learn something more about
fire extinguishers or
um you know a new system for doing
something related to the EMR and do you
look at that kind of
issue as something that needs to be
looked at in other words
it's great to come up with a new program
that's going to work better than the
last one but it's a new program and now
everybody has to adapt to it and how
does that affect
the job I would say I I think we've all
experienced that um I don't know that
we've talked about that specifically as
a group but I think that that's a great
point to bring forward that we're aware
that we just add and add an ad
um but looking at
when you add it all together what your
actual job is and the time that we have
to do it I think that contributes to the
level of burnout overwhelm
um and the challenges and getting our
jobs done so I think that that's
something we can certainly bring back to
the commission as a discussion point so
thank you anyone else before you leave
representative Edwards and I have
decided to learn BSL which is Bureau
speak as a second language and having
tracked you today all you missed were in
insularity granular and
intersectionalism you had everyone and
I'm learning so thank you and thank you
for your presentation as well thank you
thank you and before I call the next
group up and this should be pleased in
the minutes
um it is not the responsibility of an
individual member
to get his or her replacement that is
not that person's job it goes first to
me and then to the speaker's office who
then makes the appointment and secondly
do not if you're not going to be here do
not inform me at 10 o'clock in the
morning of the meeting
um several people here are not here a
few informed me of that representative
Edwards is laid up from foot surgery
representative McDonald called me others
did not and I've been working the phones
as you have seen to try to do that so
please if you can't be here let me know
as soon as you know that I have two
alternates but when I've got the
alternates into the full-time slot and I
still don't have a quorum
I have to
do a lot of work in real time so just
for the minutes and going forward
thank you
next Adverse Events
annual report
and I'm going to guess this is Doreen
Shockley and Lizette we sent what am I
doing
yeah it's right here in the text too
good morning my name is
supervisor at Health Facilities
Administration certification unit
good morning my name is Doreen Shockley
I am the manager at the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
department and we're happy to report to
you today
so I'm here to present a 2022 adverse
event reports so first and foremost it
is important to remember that consumers
should not compare the quality of care
and safety of the facilities but a
number of types of Adverse Events
reported consumers need to look at all
factors such as the size of the facility
scope and complexity of services offered
the number of services performed at the
facilities as well New Hampshire
hospitals contain to face challenges
during this covid-19 endemic I mean
you've heard from the previous
presentation
for our Adverse Events report we utilize
the National Quality Forum adverse event
list as a basis for the state mandatory
adverse event Reporting System there has
not been any recent updates to that
guide guidelines and in 2022 we have
seen an increase of Adverse Events
reported compared to previous years with
a total of 118 Adverse Events reported
for for 2022 I did have a report I just
want to make sure you upgrade
before you move on you are seeing an
increase in adverse reports is that
because there are more adverse reports
or better reporting
um at this time it's more Adverse Events
report
um let's see
um there are top there's top three
adverse event categories that was
reported
um that continues to be reported
um
which is surgical events Care events
relate to pressure injuries and Care
events related to Falls so pressure
injuries virtual 41 this year which is
found on page six Falls were 40 which is
found on page seven and surgical events
um are 14 which is found on page eight
concerning that these event types
represent about 81 percent of the total
reportable events we continue to focus
our efforts on these and address what
the New Hampshire hospital and
ambulatory surgical centers are doing in
these areas to improve which is found on
page six to nine our department does
conduct 10 sample audits quarterly for
the
2022 calendar year and adverse event
reports selected were in random for this
audit taking into consideration the
sample would include the most reported
Adverse Events and the least reported
Adverse Events and our department
concluded that the New Hampshire
hospitals and numbers are ambulatory
surgical centers follow through with
their corrective action plans to address
and correct the problems identified
through their root cause analysis
reports
pretty much do you have any questions
anybody this thus far any questions thus
far representative Murphy oh thank you I
was reading the reporting just a simple
question I believe why is it that New
Hampshire hospital is not required to
report the Adverse Events
why are they accept it out the New
Hampshire
except it says you know I'll have to
report seriously except for New
Hampshire hospital so I will confirm
that but um our law
exempts state-owned and operated
facilities from a lot of the
requirements and regulations
um and I think like we don't do
inspections at state-owned
um that might be because we're also
state employees and that's a conflict
they have accrediting agencies that do
the work that we do but I will confirm
that that's my
guessn from the hospital Association who
I've not yet been able to get to speak
today of nodded affirmatively that's
correct thank you Paula so that that's
why Hampstead Hospital does report but
the US Hospital does not well Hampstead
historically has but Hampstead going
forward will not will not okay thank you
anyone else questions thus far in the
report and seeing none please continue
I'm actually done
I mean you want to save five minutes for
next time you come because you're really
short here yes last time we actually
used an additional 10 minutes remember
no so we're even now no I don't but
thank you thank you any other questions
yes representative Murphy to the rescue
thank you thank you um the the number of
total was 118 is that up because of
covid or is that up actually as a number
relative to where we were in 2019
um and the reason I asked that question
80 out of the 118 are really
um bedside in a sense you know care
problems in is that just related to
Staffing and the inability to take care
of roll a patient get a patient out of
bed safely that sort of thing
um yes it's definitely Staffing
challenges has definitely affected
patient care and that's why you see you
know the increase of the pressure
injuries the increase of the falls and
if you really look at the numbers it's
really more bedside you know with the
Travelers consistencies definitely you
know
um kind of a problem and even right now
it's kind of still we're still trying to
I mean you have your hospital so it's
trying to kind of still recover and work
on a better consistency with their
Staffing so they can provide more
consistent patient care and we do see a
lot of sicker patients that means their
the hospitalizations our
hospitalizations are prolonged so
they're in the hospitals more in their
risk of getting this pressure injuries
and risk for their Falls has increased
as well so
is there a mechanism whereby you look at
the number of incidences in a certain
category as a function of total patient
census because if your census is high
you're going to have more but if we
don't know the census is high that data
may not tell us whether things have
gotten worse
or it's just there's more so is there a
way to analyze data in that yeah we
don't really track like the census on
the hospital that's why when I mentioned
earlier like when we when you look at my
report you have to also consider like
where the hospitals are like the scope
severity that they uh services that they
offer the facility like how big the
facility is
um we really track like that they're
reporting Adverse Events that they're
actually doing their root cause analysis
to address those concerns and come up
with a corrective action plan
so I don't really we I do work closely
with the New Hampshire hospital team
commission um just to kind of make sure
like they're aware of this and this is
like the numbers are high and not
they're at least working collaboratively
to kind of work on looking at you know
what what are the big issues what are
the
things that they could do better work on
or kind of
find more better newer
interventions I guess and sure
recognizes please tell me your name
come on up to a microphone near you you
can come up to the big people's table or
the big people stable
either one
see the senator gets to pick them up I
don't know if I should sit
so yeah
okay thank you
um so Chris Herring uh vice president
for quality improvement and at the
foundation healthy communities and
administrator for the New Hampshire
Healthcare quality and patient safety
commission thank you so much
um chairman Pearson for asking about
census and that was just something that
I wanted this commission to understand
is that at the end of 2020 and through
the first three quarters of 2021
hospital inpatient census was down
significantly if you can recall those
dark days of covid we had stopped
elective surgeries
there were patients that we expected
influx obviously those patients that
were critically ill were were in the
hospital otherwise patients were staying
away and a lot of them deferred Health
Care during that time so while our
Adverse Events during those those years
that period of time are down our patient
inpatient days were down significantly
in the end of 2021 and throughout 2022
the exact opposite
inpatient days at an all-time high
Hospital capacity at approximately 98
percent
hospitals at capacity or above capacity
and many instances so patient days
higher
Adverse Events also have been higher so
if there could be some mechanism it
could be data for those scientifically
minded or narrative for Liberal Arts
kids like me it would avoid the shock I
don't mind the Shockley but I do mind
the shock sorry value of seeing a spike
in numbers without a narrative
explaining what is going wrong with our
hospitals nothing they're morbids are
filled that would be helpful in some way
of reporting going forward thank you
because I want to make you guys look as
good as you are
thank you and there are mechanisms in
some places where we report for example
um there's ndnqi it's a national
database for nursing quality indicators
and in reporting those nursing nursing
quality measures there is a denominator
that includes
patient days or a number of encounters
or whatnot so that you can do that
comparison but we don't have that but
thank you for that for that
recommendation you're welcome
thank you for your report
and before we come to the next uh people
to come up uh again uh adding to the
notes back under Alzheimer's the chair
appoints uh The Honorable Dr Jeff
soloway is an adjunct member to the
Alzheimer's group
he had served in health and human
services and elderly Affairs committee
for six years he had served on this
committee for two years he's an
epidemiologist by training and when we
were chatting about something totally
unrelated he said could I be in some way
on that committee and I said I'm going
to have to find out what the some way is
but I have the authority to add him I've
already discussed it with a Justice
Jessica Escalon who is soon to be
talking with newly elected chairman
Senator avar that Dr soloway will be
present and speaking we seldom vote in
these things so it'll be an adjunct
member I also wish to thank before I
forget it Christina Daya fulfilling in
uh for representative not right I keep
doing that to him and it's it's not nice
um uh counselor
John Williams that's the guy thank you
for filling in so much appreciate that
she recognizes now uh
Michelle Roberts and Whitney Hammond and
this is for a review of something
book
does does that mean that's on yes
a good afternoon not yet we're on time
um so I'm Whitney Hammond I'm the acting
bureau chief for the Bureau of
prevention and wellness in the division
of Public Health Services in the
Department of Health and Human Services
good morning representative Pearson and
members of the committee my name is
Michelle Roberge I'm the bureau chief
for public health protection within the
DHA still working on the French accent
aren't you yeah
um so with me today is Whitney and
Whitney will be the one that'll be
discussing this item with you this
morning
foreign
so hopefully everybody has copies of the
letter that we submitted
um so I'll go over what's in there so
pursuant to hb2 chapter 79 429 to laws
of 2023 funding
um was appropriated for the Department
to conduct the third phase of our
community response to cancer concerns in
Merrimack New Hampshire uh pursuant to
hb2 chapter 79 429.2 we were to come
before this committee prior to using
that appropriation for review
that appropriation included five hundred
thousand dollars to be used in this
state biennium which ends June 30th 2025
to be able to contract with an academic
or research organization who would be
able to conduct what we call a
feasibility study which is really
focused on determining if there would be
potential to actually apply for and get
funding for a full epidemiological study
looking at kidney cancers and
environmental exposures in Merrimac
pursuant to hb2 language the department
was asked to identify if there was any
other funding Federal funding grant
funding non-state funds that might be
available to support that feasibility
study
so
um the the department has done their due
diligence in looking for that funding we
routinely and systematically monitor for
Federal grant funding we work closely
with our federal agencies who provide
funding so the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention is one of our
primary Federal funders and we are not
aware of any funding that would support
this feasibility study and for a little
bit of extra context a lot of the
funding that we get is to support Public
Health response and the work of the
public health agencies and this stage of
the you know Community response that
includes a feasibility study really
represents a step further than public
health response and more research work
and so there aren't typically research
grants that the department applies for
we have worked with academic Partners to
see if their grant funding opportunity
communities that might be available for
them to apply for and have also not
identified any funding
any questions
does anyone have a question thus far
seeing none you may continue
okay I think that's pretty much it we
just wanted to thank representative
Nancy Murphy representative Erica Leon
and representative Maureen Mooney who
have been so helpful in getting this
appropriation and enabling the
department to continue our response to
the concerns of Merrimack
so thank you good
good
well that's it unless anybody in the
committee has anything I would like to
see associate commission ahen up here at
the end please then we are done with 20
minutes to spare wow no no I mean up
here here not up there here